في نادي سويسري لكره القدم اسمه حب انه
يطفي لمسه فنيه على الكلب هاوس وغرف تغيير
ملابس اللاعبين ويزينها وما يتركها ممله
وبيضاء
معين فنانتين تشكيليتين وكلهم بهذه المهمه
الفنانين يعني خلينا نقول انهم هم من
المعروفين بانهم ابانكارد
بيقدم وفن تقدمي ومختلف لكن الحقيقه يا
ريتهم
ولا تعبوا حالهم وخلوا الجدران فاضيه كان
اكرم لهم ولا كان جابوني انا ارسم عليها
وانا متاكد انه معك كل ضعفي في الرسم راح
يكون رسمه احسن لانه اللي راح تشوفوه
امامكم الان هو النتيجه النهائيه يعني
انتم شايفين الان الان هل يعقل يعني هل
هذا الكلام معقول
الكارثه الكبرى مو هنا بس العمل الفني
اللي شفتوه اندفع فيه للفنانتين 28000
دولار او لا لا دولار ايه 28,000 يورو
متخيلين يعني ارجع بالله يوروني العمل على
الفني عن قرب ثاني متخيلين انه انتم هذا
الفن اندفع في قدرنا نسميه فن يعني اندفع
في 28,000 يورو عموما اللاعبين طردوا
واحتجوا حتى واحد منهم اول ما دخل الغرفه
انفجع وفكر انه في ناس اقتحامه المكان
وخربوه بصراحه ما ينلام ولما الصور انتشرت
اون لاين الناس كمان علقت واحتجت وسخرت
بصراحه ووصف العمل الفني بخربش الاطفال
اعتقد برده كمان هذا الوصف يعني صراحه في
ظل يخرب الاطفال كمان